detectives may have recovered crucial
new evidence in the death of Penn State
student Timothy Piazza the results of an
investigation into surveillance video of
the fraternity basement where he was
found
will be announced later today 19
year-old Piazza died after an alleged
hazing ritual the district attorney
alleges the video was deleted to cover
up potential crimes Anna Werner is
outside the Bellefonte Pennsylvania
courthouse where the announcement will
be made today anna good morning good
morning well much of the district
attorney's case here is built around
those surveillance videos taken that
night at the fraternity house but video
from one surveillance camera out of the
basement was missing now it appears the
DA may have cleared that hurdle timothy
Piazza's final hours were captured by
surveillance cameras inside the Beta
Theta Pi house but investigators believe
crucial minutes from a basement camera
had been deleted by a fraternity member
last week district attorneys Stacy
Parkes Miller sent out a press release
suggesting that footage has been
recovered the statement said the
basement video captures the ongoing
hazing and the continued repeated
furnishing of alcohol by beta brothers -
Tim Piazza we spoke to parks Miller in
August if it was deleted why would you
delete that it must contain something
you know more damaging or incriminating
prosecutors say Piazza died from
injuries sustained during a hazing
ceremony that involved heavy drinking
and started in the basement last week
Penn State said it disciplined seven of
the students involved with penalties
ranging from probation to expulsion
Parks Miller previously told us she
might seek additional criminal charges
if the basement video could be recovered
so who deleted the video and what
charges might they be facing we're not
ready to disclose who you know the
charges could be obstruction of justice
and a couple other things that cover
that crime the Piazza family's attorney
told CBS this morning the expected
announcement is a significant
development which has the capacity to
dramatically affect the prosecution of
the individuals who were responsible for
Tim Piazza's tragic and unnecessary
death the Piazza family plans to attend
the DA's announcement this after
in her press conference a judge has
already thrown out the most serious
charges against the 16 fraternity
members indicted in this case Gail Hart
certainly go out to the Piazza family
but this could be the break they've been
hoping for thank you very much Hannah